peu plus
[Musique]
tu vas dans le rouge rouge d'horribles
rouge c'est le meilleur c'était
plausible et marchera pas jugé lundi 5 à
17 ans voilà aujourd'hui mais j'ai fait
mes études de médecine à partir de 1958
à montpellier lui en tout et pour tout
ça fait ça m'a fait faire dix ans
d'études dé 6,1 à médecine générale le
stage interne et et 3,1 de spécialité
pour m'installer
après mon service militaire cardiologue
après avoir cherché un point de chute
qui s'est avérée être la ville de hyères
bonjour d'affilée
5e et les 10 et les voies journée je
vais dessiner rempli c'est ma vie
complètement je travaillais énormément
je combine c'est vers 7 heures du matin
je finissais vers 22h30
je ne voyais pas très peu famille en fin
en donnant utilise que nous adorions
nous avions très peu d'activités
parallèles
je gagnais bien ma vie autrefois je la
gagne certaines mains actuellement moins
bien mais je la gagne quand même très
correctement et ni moi ni ma femme
n'avait jamais considéré que l'argentin
faisait faisait tout dans la vie des
rigidités souple même leader ça ira oui
voilà trente ans et les 50 ce sera moins
lourd comme ça et il a progressé ce
jeudi un notable je crois que j'étais
considéré un peu comme tel
personnellement j jamais tâche est trop
important ça par contre c'est sûr que
parce que je me promener en ville au
bout de quelques années d'installation
mes filles étaient très fiers de voir
que un peu partout sur les trottoirs on
me salue et de me respecter certaines
eaux mettrait ici à l'alpe d'huez je
crois que je ne suis plus au nota je
suis une conversion comme aux autres on
n'est pas contre 2 chez les copains je
suis un copain je suis plus aux notables
[Musique]
alors ben sont les génériques de mails
je connais les joueurs actuels
donnez donnez et b donc c'est que je
suis un bout de scotch sur doctor
session bout de stoke
si vous faites les autres j'ai que du
léger aussi séduit les jeunes ça fait
rire ça vous fera moins de mal alors
attendez même sans merci
voilà 26 60 disent merci
alors j'ai changé parce que je
considérais que à mon avis personnel
depuis les années 60 78 médecine évoluer
vers une modification de sa gestion sur
le plan national et économique et que
cette évolution ne me convenait pas tout
simplement j'ai un esprit forcément
forcené en tant que libéralisme et
l'évolution qui sont haussiers qui a
l'air de se confirmer actuellement fait
que nous allons vers un dirigisme et qui
sera de mise en plus autoritaire et
c'était pas cet homme est le signe là
que je voulais faire alors qu'est-ce que
nous avons deux
80 élevée 14,5 entre les deux sont de 3
ans qui était folle et autres il est
vain voilà ça va mais est-ce que des
bruits ont couru sur vous
donc est-ce que des bruits ont couru
sans vous hier j'ai su que sur rien même
ici des bruits avaient couru concernant
éventuellement raisons de mon départ
si on ma vie privée sur ma vie
professionnelle je comptais ça et on
peut aller vite et il faut se mettre
derrière il sait pas si l'état nous ont
raconté que j'avais eu des problèmes
d'ordre professionnel éventuellement des
qui avait contraint qui avait fait des
procès que j'avais été éventuellement
sanctionné par la sécurité sociale ce
qu'il faut que j'avais des problèmes
dans ma vie privée avec ma femme de tas
de choses mais aucune n'était vrai oui
bien sûr je vais voter sur voilà elle
est à venir pour gérer un tabac presse
jeux presse c'est qu'il faut moins de
matière grise et que pour que pour faire
de la cardiologie
mais il en faut quand même suffisamment
dans le contexte économique actuel
pourront pas faire de bêtises et pour
avoir une gestion extrêmement serrés
qu'ils fassent la queue en fin de saison
se retrouve quand même de plomb mais par
contre ce qui est certain c'est que il
ya deux différences fondamentales la
matière grise est essentielle en
cardiologie dans le commerce sont les
capitaux les investissements en place la
matière grise de 20 euros
un terrain souple gemalto est tellement
que voulait alors il n'a rien que
amicalement sur certains symptômes on me
demande des conseils amicaux et même
peut arriver qu'on m'a demandé quelques
conseils ils ont deux rencontres
fraternelles également en matière de
cardiologie
ça m'a gêné par le vent roger tabah en
tagalog a vu que peut être car de
l'homme pour moi c'est quand même a dû
passer maintenant je suis je suis une
conversion quand d'autres
[Musique]